[Applaus]
[Musik]
sei es durch tote Fische in der oder die
Weigerung Flüchtlinge aufzunehmen oder
durch Verdächtige Experimente mit der
Rechtsstaatlichkeit Polen war in den
letzten Jahren oft mit negativ
Schlagzeilen in den Nachrichten erst
sagt man dort wie kaum ein anderes Land
in Europa treu an der Seite der Ukraine
steht hat sich die Meinung der
Weltöffentlichkeit über das
mitteleuropäische Land wieder gedreht
dabei gab es eigentlich schon davor
viele gute Nachrichten aus Polen kaum
ein anderes der alten Ostblockländer hat
sich sowohl wirtschaftlich wie auch im
Blick auf die Institutionen so gut
entwickelt wie Polen hier war die
Hinwendung zum besten eine echte
Erfolgsgeschichte und zwar eine viel
größere Erfolgsgeschichte also manchen
anderen EU-Ländern lieb ist
in diesem Video werden wir uns deswegen
den neuen platzpools in der Europäischen
Gemeinschaft anschauen denn diese
Erfolgsgeschichte war vor allem in den
letzten Jahren durch viele Zwistigkeiten
gekennzeichnet wieso oft beginnen wir
daher erst einmal mit einem kurzen Blick
in die Geschichte
denn Polen hat vielleicht eine der
spannendsten und vor allem
wechselvollsten Historien aller Länder
Europas wir beschränken uns heute daher
auf das 20 Jahrhundert und wie gesagt
das Ergebnis dieser Entwicklung wird
eine der erfolgreichsten Hinwendung zum
Westen mit seinem System und Lebensstil
sein in die Geschichte bisher gesehen
hat aber wusstet ihr auch dass die
bestwertbewegung Polens nicht nur im
übertragenen Sinne gilt richtig Polen
hat sich in den letzten 100 Jahren auch
physisch nach besten verschoben es
durchlief eine der abwechslungsreichsten
aber auch eine der kompliziertesten
Geschichten des 20 Jahrhunderts zunächst
zwischen österreich-russland und
Deutschland aufgeteilt weiß in beiden
Weltkriegen Schauplatz viele Kämpfe
wurde zunächst unabhängig kam dann unter
deutsche und sowjetischer Herrschaft bis
es schließlich ganz ein Satelliten UdSSR
wurde so ging es bis 1989 dann errangen
auch die Polen ihre Unabhängigkeit
stürmische Zeiten also inzwischen sieht
das Schicksal des Landes jedoch ganz
anders aus seitdem Beitritt zur
Europäischen Union im Jahr 2004 ist
Polen als der wirtschaftliche
erfolgreich anderen Länder Europas sein
BIP ist zwischen 204 und 2021 und sagte
164% gestiegen
das Wachstum lag in diesem Zeitraum
sogar 20% über den in Tschechien Polen
liegt dabei nur knapp hinter Estland und
Litauen es war der erfolgreichsten
Länder in Europa während des letzten
Jahrzehnts zum Vergleich im gleichen
Zeitraum wuchsen die Volkswirtschaften
Spaniens und Italiens um 34 bzw 16
Prozent Polen hat sich also dank seiner
relativ billigen und gut qualifizierten
Arbeitskräfte zu einem industriellen
Epizentrum entwickelt auch wenn es noch
einen langen Weg vor sich hat um mit dem
weiterentwickelten Europa gleichzuziehen
außerdem hat es mit seinen 38 Millionen
Einwohnern ein erhebliches
demografisches Gewicht auf dem alten
Kontinent so stellt Polen zum Beispiel
die fünf größten landesdelegationen
Abgeordneten im Europäischen Parlament
mit 52 und insgesamt 75 Mitgliedern also
durchaus entscheidender Block zudem und
wie wir euch hier auf visualpolitik
schon berichtet haben auch das Land eine
der größten Streitkräfte des gesamten
auf und wenn man all das berücksichtigt
könnte man meinen dass Polen alle
Voraussetzungen dazu hat um eines der
stärksten und einflussreichsten Länder
in der EU zu werden
[Musik]
aber mal langsam eine Schwalbe macht
noch keine Frühling und solche
Kennzahlen sagen allein auch erstmal
nicht viel aus die polnische Entwicklung
ist stark von der Europäischen Union und
deren Vorteilen abhängig denn auf der
einen Seite ist es der größte Empfänger
von EU Fördergeldern und auf der anderen
Seite gibt es nur wenige andere Länder
in der EU die sich so wenig dem
Mainstream in der Gemeinschaft anpassen
wollen also liebe visualpolitik
Zuschauer die Preisfrage dieses Videos
lautet inwieweit könnte Polen zu einem
echten machtpolitischen Schwergewicht
Inhalte EU und damit in ganz Europa
werden kann es die Achse Paris Berlin
ernsthaft herausfordern und das macht
Zentrum Europas den Osten verschieben
schnallt euch an den heute geht es um
nichts anderes als die zukünftige
Marschrichtung der ganzen EU wir legen
gleich los nach einem kurzen
Werbehinweis unseres tollen Sponsors
surfshark GPS dann wirklich
empfehlenswertes und sicheres VPN
welches social keinerlei
Verbindungsdaten mit lockt natürlich
kann ein Virtual Private Network kurz
VPN einen nicht vor allen
gefahrenschützen denen man muss nach wie
vor um sich weiter lassen und wissen was
man tut aber es stellt hierfür ein
Werkzeug mit Recht mehreren Vorteilen da
zum einen erschwert es im Kombination
mit anderen Vorkehrungen eure Aktionen
des nachzuverfolgen und abzuhören mit
Hilfe verschiedener Sicherheitsfeatures
könnt ihr so eure Anonymität im Netz
erhöhen z.B mit dem integrierten
klimberg das alle Cookies und Poppers
blockt weiterer Vorteil eines VPN ist
dass ihr so tun könnt als wäre dir an
einem anderen Ort so könnt ihr z.B auch
Website und Internetdienste zugreifen in
dem Land in dem wir gerade seid nicht
verfügbar wären auf deinem oder Urlaub
damit schlagt die Zensur und gioblocking
ein Schnäppchen Netflix und anderes
Streamingdienste die ihre Inhalte nur in
den USA Anbieten von Europa ausnutzen
oder deutsches Internetfernsehen im
Ausland gucken mit surfshark kein
Problem aber das ist noch lange nicht
alles denn mit nur einem surfshark Konto
könnt ihr wirklich alle eure Endgeräte
im VPN registrieren Handys Notebooks
oder sogar euren Smart TV so und zum
Black Friday hast surfshark ein
besonderes Angebot für euch auf Lager
wenn ihr den rabattpolitik.de angeht
bekommt ihr von surfshark einen Rabatt
in Höhe von 85% und obendrein die ersten
drei Monate GRA dazu greift am besten
jetzt zu denn dieses Angebot ist
zeitlich limitiert den Link dazu findet
ihr in der Beschreibung unter diesem
Video also nichts wie los besorgt euch
zu auch schon greift damit auch
gleichzeitig uns finanzielle unter die
Arme das könnte übrigens auch direkt mit
Hilfe eines PayPal Spenden links den ich
euch ebenfalls in die Beschreibung
gepackt habe wir sind euch für jede
Unterstützung dank bei den damit helft
ihr uns euch in Zukunft noch mehr und
noch bessere Videos zu liefern so und
nun macht euch bereit wir begeben uns
auf eine Reise ins neue starke Europa
jenseits der Oder und Neiße
[Musik]
das schwarze Schaf in der Herde
man kann es nicht anders sagen der
polnische Fall ist kompliziert gut die
letzten Jahrzehnte waren für Polen
unterm Strich eine echte
Erfolgsgeschichte aber trotzdem läuft
nicht alles rund für kontrollversen hat
in den letzten Jahren vor allem die
aktuelle Regierungspartei PES gesagt die
Partei Recht und Gerechtigkeit und zwar
besonders durch ihren Streit den sie mit
der EU vom Zaun gebrochen hat grund
dafür waren vor allem neue Gesetze zur
Kontrolle der Judikative durch die
Exekutive aber auch eine stark
wertkonservative Haltung in
gesellschaftspolitischen Fragen dazu
kommen noch nationalistische
populistische und bisweilen sogar
euroskeptische Untertitel das alles hat
Polen in augenbrüssel zu einem schwarzen
Schaf in der europäischen Herde gemacht
das Ziel der PES war vom ersten Moment
an traditionelle Werte und Grundsätze
des Landes gegen das progressive
narrativ aus Brüssel zu verteidigen ein
narrativ zu dessen grundsätzlich
eigentlich alle EU-Staaten unter Artikel
2 des EU-Vertrages einmal verpflichtet
hatten kurzum ist krachte in den
innereuropäischen Beziehungen besonders
gespürt hat man das in den Beziehungen
zwischen Polen und Deutschland über
viele Jahre hatte sich die einstige
Feindschaft beide Länder zu einer guten
Freundschaft entwickelt im Besonderen
galt das für die 7 Jahre unter der
Regierung Donald Trump bevor die PES
2015 an die Macht kam
seit 2015 aber wurde diese neue
Freundschaft zunehmend in Frage gestellt
und das ist noch freundlich formuliert
man könnte auch sagen die Freundschaft
wurde regelrecht auf Eis gelegt
vielleicht sogar zerbrochen denn hört
euch mal an womit Vertreter der PES
offen gegen ihren Nachbarland Polter
schaut man auf die Vorgänge in der EU so
besteht kein Zweifel daran dass Europa
ein Kontinent unter deutscher Hegemonie
ist das ist Errichtung des vierten
Reichs Martin Romanowski und der
Staatssekretär im Justizministerium wir
passen nicht in die deutsch-russischen
Pläne über Europa zu herrschen ein
unabhängiges wirtschaftlich sozial und
militärisch starkes Polen ist für sie
ein Hindernis aus historischer Sicht ist
das nichts Neues Jahreswagen Parteichef
der PES harte Wörter nicht wahr und
damit nicht genug
erst kürzlich pünktlich zum Tag der
Deutschen Einheit forderte Warschau
wieder kriegsreparation für den zweiten
Weltkrieg erlittenen Schäden dabei reden
wir nicht von Peanuts die ausgleichstone
wurde auf etwa 1,3 Billionen Euro
bezahlt keine Summe die man ernsthaft
meint zu erhalten alles deutet darauf
hin dass die P ist bemüht ist
Deutschland als in den nächsten großen
stromanfeind aufzubauen um daraus bei
den Wahlen 2023 Kapital zu schlagen so
wird beispielsweise die zeitweise
polnische Isolierung innerhalb der EU
auf eine deutsche Verschwörung
zurückgeführt ein weiterer Aspekt der so
Abkühlung der Beziehungen Paris und
Brüssel beigetragen hat war die
Weigerung der Pole 2005 bekannten und
Flüchtlingen aus dem Nahen Osten und
Afrika aufzunehmen zur Begründung hieß
es damals es handelt sich eben nicht um
Flüchtlinge sondern auch um
Wirtschaftsmigranten ergo besteht keine
Verpflichtung zur Aufnahme eine Position
die Polen zumindest in Teilen der EU das
Image eines unsolidarischen und
fremdenfeindlichen landeseinbrachte
sprich Polen war nicht mehr weit davon
entfernt innerhalb der EU als Paria
behandelt zu werden und genügend
Journalisten hatten diese Bezeichnung
das vorweggenommen
aber das alles hat auch knallharte
praktische Folgen so blockierte die
Europäische Union zum Beispiel die
Auszahlung von 36 Milliarden Euro an
Polen auf die das Land aus kowithilfen
eigentlich Anspruch gehabt hätte
tatsächlich war das noch bis vor kurzem
der Fall erst durch Polens neue Rolle im
Ukraine Krieg hat sich die Lage wieder
entspannt wenn auch nicht ganz
mai 2022 EU schließt Vereinbarung mit
Polen über 36 Milliarden Euro für
covic-konjunkturprogramm abposten steht
kurz vor einer Einigung mit Polen um
nach einem halben Jahr des Stillstands
Dutzende von Milliarden Euro an
Zuschüssen und Darlehen freizugeben so
ein hoher EU-Beamter juli 2022 Brüssel
stellt bei der Freigabe von
eu-rettungsgeldern Polens Justizreform
in Frage holen uns erste Auszahlung von
EU rettungsgeldern könnte sich verzögern
nachdem die Europäische Kommission
festgestellt hat dass ein
Schlüsselelement in den vorgeschlagenen
Justizreform des Landes fehlt das
vielleicht bemerkenswerteste bei all dem
ist jedoch das dicke Fell dass man in
Warschau gegen die Angriffe aus Brüssel
entwickelt hat
in vielen Punkten unbeeindruckt dies man
eine eu-sanktion nach der nächsten
Übersicht ergeben man liest sich bisher
einfach nicht mit Geld erpressen wenn es
um die eigenen Grundsätze gehen aber
auch jetzt geht der Streit zwischen
Brüssel und Warschau in einem Neuerungen
hielt sich die EU-Kommission wegen der
großen Ukraine Hilfe bei schaust bisher
mit Sanktionen gegenüber dem
rechtsstaatssünder zurück drückt Brüssel
nun überraschend damit Strukturmittel in
Höhe von sage und schreibe 75 Milliarden
Euro zurückzuhalten Ursula von der Leyen
geht damit jedoch ein sehr großes Risiko
ein in den Polen stehen wie gesagt 2023
Parlamentswahlen an und die PS wird die
Angriffe ausbrutzelt ganz sicher zu
ihrem Vorteil ausschlachten die
polnische Regierung schafft es nämlich
regelmäßig die EU-Kommission vorzuführen
zum Beispiel indem sie Zugeständnis an
einer Stelle macht ihre Ziele jedoch
woanders wieder durchdrückt denn so
erstaunlich es auch klingen mag im
Paragraphen dicke ich das polnischen
Rechtssystems verlieren selbst die
Brüste Bürokraten oft den Überblick der
Hauptgrund für das große
Selbstbewusstsein der ist jedoch ein
ganz anderer in den letzten Jahren hat
Polen eine sehr starke regionale Rolle
im Osten Europas entwickelt es wurden
Bündnisse geschlossen wie die bische
gradgruppe oder die drei Meere
Initiative über die wir hier auf
visualpolitik schon berichtet haben ich
werde euch wie gesagt die entsprechenden
Videos in der Beschreibung unten
verlinken das alles war jedoch erst der
Anfang denn spätestens seit der
russischen Invasion in die Ukraine wurde
klar dass die Rolle Polens viel
wichtiger ist als irgendjemand gedacht
hätte auch gepasst
[Musik]
das osteuropäische Paradigma
die gemeinsame Geschichte Polens und der
Ukraine war nicht immer so idyllisch wie
die Freundschaft die sie heute verbindet
vor wenigen Jahren noch ergaben Umfragen
dass sie Ukraine das Volk waren dass man
in Polen am wenigsten mochte gleich nach
den Rumänen
die historische Beziehung zwischen Polen
und Ukrainern hat viele dunkle Episoden
erlebt in den Jahren 1943 und 44 wurden
zum Beispiel schätzungsweise 70 bis
100.000 Polen Indien von ukrainischen
nationalistischen Partisanen aus dem
Umfeld von Stefan bandera ermordet ihre
Intention war die Region oscalizien die
heute zur Ukraine gehört ethnisch zu
säubern damit sie nie wieder polnisch
werde und der polnische Widerstand
tötete seinerseits zwischen 20 und
25.000 ukrainische Dorfbewohner aber was
wohl in der Vergangenheit am meisten
gestört hat war das einige der Täter
dieser Massaker in der Ukraine als
Nationalhelden verehrt werden
2018 hat das polnische Parlament sogar
ein Gesetz verabschiedet dass die
Leugnung von Verbrechen der ukrainischen
Nationalisten unter Strafe stellt
trotzdem hat sich die Lage in den
letzten Jahren radikal verändert
[Musik]
tatsächlich sind Polen und die Ukraine
das lebende Beispiel dafür dass es in
vielen Fällen die bestmögliche
Entscheidung ist historische
Streitigkeiten beizulegen wir reden hier
über zwei Länder die schon lange vor der
russischen Invasion enge Verbündete
waren und jetzt sind sie sich natürlich
noch näher gekommen doch man hat nicht
nur militärisch kooperiert Polen der
richtig ukrainische Regierung seit
Jahren bei der Frage welche Reformen
durchgeführt werden müssen und wie das
Land seine Wirtschaft seine
Institutionen sein politisches System
verbessern kann um sich auf einen
eventuellen Beitrag zur EU vorzubereiten
ja man könnte fast sagen dass Polen für
die Ukraine eine Art Mentor geworden ist
ganz zu schweigen davon dass ukrainische
Migranten schon vor den Flugbewegungen
während des Krieges die größte
Einwanderergruppe in Polen darstellten
aber die Frage die sich sicher viele von
euch stellen ist warum in aller Welt
kommen zwei Länder die sich
jahrzehntelang praktisch gehasst haben
jetzt so gut miteinander aus nun es ist
wie so oft die Interessen haben sich
verändert ein starkes Bündnis lag nicht
mehr nur im Interesse der Ukraine
sondern nun auch im Mittelpunkt der
strategischen Interessen Polens und das
gleich aus mehreren Gründen
einerseits ist die Ukraine für Warschau
eine Art Puffer oder Sicherheitszone
gegen Russland wenn man mal von der
russischen Exklave um Königsberg herum
absieht und diese Rolle der Ukraine
wurde von Warschau gerade während des
Kriegs noch mal bekräftigt wo immer wir
in Europa leben müssen wir uns bewusst
sein dass die Ukraine nicht nur ihre
Unabhängigkeit und Souveränität
verteidigen sondern auch Europa als
Ganzes putin wird niemals aufhören er
wird sein Imperium immer weiter
ausdehnen Matteo schmoraviewski
polnische Premierminister auf der
anderen Seite ermöglicht die Ukraine
Polen seine Macht und Einflussbereich in
ganz Europa erheblich auszuhalten das
gilt umso mehr wenn die Ukraine in
Zukunft Mitglieder Europäischen Union
sein wird zusammen hätten beide Länder
mehr als 80 Millionen Einwohner also
etwa so viele wie Deutschland damit
könnte man auch mit den unliebsamen
deutschen Block in den EU-Institutionen
gleich aufziehen wenn wir dazu noch
andere Länder berücksichtigen die Polen
politische nahe stehen wie die
baltischen Staaten oder die Slowakei
oder Warschau zu einer der
einflussreichsten Hauptstädte des alten
Kontinents werden und nach der
klassischen Invasion der Ukraine sind
diese Rolle und die Ambitionen Polens
deutlicher den je geborgen Polen ist zum
Beispiel nicht nur das Land das im
ganzen östlichen Mitteleuropa am meisten
für die Verteidigung ausgeht sondern
seine Anstrengungen werden sich in den
kommenden Jahren noch einmal
vervielfachen um eine der stärksten
armenen ganz Europa aufzubauen Polen
verdoppelt seine Militärausgaben während
der Krieg in der Ukraine tobt Polen war
seine Militärausgaben im nächsten Jahr
mehr als verdoppeln und zwar auf bis zu
138 Milliarden Worten das sind 29
Milliarden Dollar zusätzlich plant die
Regierung bis zu 40 Milliarden sowie
umgerechnet 8,56 Milliarden Dollar für
den Kauf von Waffen im Ausland
auszugeben darüber haben wir übrigens
schon in einem kürzlich erschienen Video
ausführlich gesprochen dass ich euch in
der Beschreibung verlinken werde aber es
geht beim Einfluss in der EU natürlich
nicht nur um Militärausgaben
noch wichtiger ist das Pool während des
ukrainekrieges eine führende Rolle unter
den Verbündeten übernommen hat es ist zu
einem der wichtigsten politischen
Akteure dem größten Aufnahmeland für
Flüchtlinge und einem der größten Geber
von Hilfsgütern aus der EU geworden bis
heute haben zum Beispiel mehr als 5
Millionen Ukraine Polen durchquert und
mehr als 2 Millionen leben dort seit
Kriegsbeginn seitdem die Russen ihren
Vernichtungsfeldzug gestartet haben sind
die polnischen Staatsoberhäupter immer
wieder nach Kiew gereist und haben viele
kommunikis und Erklärungen auf Englisch
abgegeben die sich vor allem an
Westeuropa richteten ja jenes Westeuropa
und westliche Mitteleuropa dass ich eben
viel langsamer und zögerlicher bewegt
hat als das östliche Mitteleuropa
doch damit nicht genug im April 22 hat
die polnische Regierung sogar eine
internationale Kampagne gestartet um die
westlichen Staats- und Regierungschefs
von Ländern wie Deutschland in
Verlegenheit zu bringen die Rede ist von
der Kampagne
#stop-rusher now die der polnische
Ministerpräsident selbst auf seinem
Twitter-Account vorgestellt hat eine
Kampagne bei der Polen auf mobilen
Plakatwänden in verschiedenen
europäischen Hauptstädten besonders
scharfen und kritischen Slogans
unterwegs war es gibt sogar einen
YouTube-Kanal der polnischen Regierung
auf den die europäischen Staats- und
Regierungschefs für ihre halbgare
Haltung bei der Unterstützung der
Ukraine angebracht werden
und auch auf der zwischenstaatlichen
Ebene hat war schon nicht gezögert und
ist federführend geworden als es um die
Antwort Europas auf die Aggressionen
Russlands ging zudem hat man sich dort
zum Anführer des Blogs von Mittel- und
osteuropäischen Ländern aufgeschwungen
die Gier besonders stark unterstützen
und Druck auf den Rest der Gemeinschaft
ausüben spätestens jetzt wurde also das
enorme politische Kapital deutlich das
war schon seit Jahren über Brüssel
hinaus aufgebaut hat überhaupt
die politische Landkarte in der EU mit
dem Krieg stark geändert ehemalige
Gegner sind Freunde geworden und alte
Freundschaften sind zerbrochen im Falle
Pols hat man sich zum Beispiel von Pro
russisch auftretenden ungarischen
Regierung distanziert und das obwohl
Orbans viele Partei eigentlich eine
lange Freundschaft mit der polnischen
pes-verband doch nun vernahmen aus
Warschau mit einem mal folgendes ich
bestätige die Worte von
Ministerpräsident Orban dass sich die
Wege Polens und Ungarns auseinander
entwickelt haben Matteo schnuraviewski
polnischer Premierminister am 29 juli
2022 und diese Trennung war ganz und gar
nicht zum Nachteil Polens warschau ist
nun unumstritten die neue
referenzhauptstadt Mittelosteuropas
vielleicht sogar ganz Mitteleuropas und
zwar vor allem in den Augen der
amerikanischen Verbündeten
wie mächtig der Block umpolen und seine
Verbündeten in Europa mittlerweile
geworden ist demonstriert eindrucksvoll
dramatische Kehrtwende in seine Haltung
gegenüber der Ukraine und Russland noch
Anfang September 22 gab er die folgenden
Worte von sich die direkt gegen die
polnische Regierung und auch gegen das
Baltikum gerichtet waren wir müssen
alles tun um einen verhandlungsfrieden
mit Russland zu ermöglichen Europa nicht
spalten zu lassen wird eine tägliche
Herausforderung für uns alle sein wir
sollten uns nicht mit den
kriegslüfternden Typen verbinden die das
Risiko eingehenden Konflikt auszuweiten
und die Kommunikation mit Russland
komplett abzuschneiden wir sollten auch
nicht in Erwägung ziehen ein paar
europäische Staaten an unserer Ostflanke
auf eigene Faust Handeln zu lassen wenn
Manuel macron französischer Präsident
tja lange hat der Präsident macron
gedacht er könnte sich als Vermittler
zwischen Putin und den Alliierten der
Ukraine profilieren die dem er versuchte
mit dem Diktator auf Augenhöhe zu
sprechen aber dass er davor warnte
Russland nicht zu brüskieren einfach mal
sowohl in Kiew als auch in Warschau als
affrong
die Verbündeten diesen Sturm gegen
Frankreich und sie hatten Erfolg
macronbegriff dass die scheinbar
kleineren Staaten zusammen doch eine
beträchtliche Macht darstellen vor allem
eine Macht die Zukunft noch weiter
wachsen und an der man nicht mehr
vorbeikommen wird geschweige denn es
sich lohnen würde gegen sie anzukämpfen
deswegen liegt er nur zwei Wochen nach
seinen verhandlungsforderungen ein und
endete seinen Standpunkt diametral bei
seiner Rede vor der
UN-Generalversammlung zeichnete er schon
ein vollkommen anderes Bild er verglicht
die jetzige Weltlage mit der während des
Zweiten Weltkriegs und beschworen
Frankreich im Kampf um die Freiheit fest
an der Seite der Alliierten zu stehen
aber er ging noch weiter niemand könne
sich auf einen neutrale Position
zurückziehen die neuen blockfreien
Staaten machten sich am Krieg
mitschuldig alle die heute Schweigen
dienen gegen ihren Willen oder mit
bewusster Komplizenschaft der Sache des
neuen Imperialismus auch wenn der
Ukraine Krieg manchen Ländern fern
scheint zwingt er alle Positionen zu
beziehen denn wir bezahlen alle den
gleichen Preis dafür emmanuell macron am
20.9.2022 vor der UN-Generalversammlung
damit hat sich der staatenblock
umwaschung herum mit seinem strikten
narrativ durchgesetzt und quasi auch die
Achse Paris Berlin zerschlagen denn
nicht nur dass der deutsche Kanzler
Scholz auch auf dieselbe Linie
einschränken musste die zuvor schon
macron Nein zwischen den einstigen
Großmächten der EU ist auch ein
veritables systembrand dieser ist jedoch
ein Thema für ein anderes Video fakt ist
das Baltikum Warschau Kiew Prag und
Bratislava haben sich damit durchgesetzt
dass du ein ganz Europa dafür eintritt
die Ukraine bis an die Ziele zu
bewaffnen Russland zu besiegen und
vollständig mit Moskau zu brechen putin
ist somit grandios gescheitert einen
Keil zwischen die Europäer zu treiben im
Grunde Arbeit ist noch bei Detailfragen
wie zum Beispiel der gaspreisbremse
Polen läuft auch hier Deutschland vor
Europa jetzt seine Energiepolitik
aufzuzwingen indem es durch massive
Energie Subventionen seine Industrie
bevorzugt und damit den Binnenmarkt
verzerrt und ein Großteil der EU steht
dabei übrigens hinter Polen auch
Frankreich denn Warschau will bereit
sein nicht nur seinen Block in Europa
anzuführen sondern die ganze Union es
möchte die sowohl aus politischer wie
auch aus wirtschaftlicher Sicht als die
größte Industriemacht der Region und
dabei geht es demonstrativ in einem doch
etwas andere Richtung als sein Nachbar
Deutschland
Polen und Südkorea unterzeichnen
Rahmenabkommen über atomkraft-projekt
sowohl und Warschau haben nach Angaben
der Ministerien beider Länder
Rahmenvereinbarungen zum ausbot der
Kernenergie in Polen unterzeichnet polen
will aus der Kohle aussteigen und seine
Kohlendioxid-Emissionen senken Leo
Südkorea versucht seine Atomindustrie
wiederzubeleben
29.10.2022 Polen lässt erst das
Atomkraftwerk von us-wärmer westinghaus
allegrade bauen vor allem aber möchte es
zur neuen großen Militär macht Europas
werden und dabei das rückständige
Deutschland demonstrativ auf die Plätze
verweisen
[Musik]
darum macht Polen den militärdeal mit
Südkorea statt mit Deutschland Polen
kauft im großen Stil Kriegsgerät in
Südkorea ein die deutsche
Rüstungsindustrie geht leer aus dahinter
steht der Plan Warschau aus wie sein
asiatisches Vorbild zu werden
hochgerüstet innovativ
wachstumsgetrieben südkorea hat das Ziel
Polen zum Zentrum für Innovation zu
machen und vielleicht zu einer Art
drehkräuter eigenen Industrie für den
europäischen Markt tja es sieht ganz
danach aus als ein stünde ein neues
macht Zentrum in der EU neben Brüssel
Paris und Berlin eine neue europäischer
Block der viel stärker pro amerikanisch
pro britisch und pronator ist und dessen
politische Position insgesamt weit vom
EU Mainstream entfernt sind
[Musik]
dessen arrogant durchgedrückte
Fehlentscheidungen der letzten zehn
Jahre die fast gänzlich auf
hypermoralisierender Ideologie basierten
denn auf Realpolitik haben die
Reputationen und das politische Kapital
der bisherigen führenden Mächte in der
EU Deutschland und Frankreich nachhaltig
ruiniert und zwar weltweit nehmen wir
das Beispiel Energiepolitik Deutschland
hat seine Seele an Putin verkauft um
sich mit Hilfe des billigen russischen
Gases zum planetenretter Aufspielen zu
können und dabei gleichzeitig einen
Reibach zu machen darüber haben wir vor
kurzem ein eigenes Video gedreht
Deutschland wollte mit seiner
Energiewende für die ganze Welt als
Beispiel vorangehen genau dies war ja
häufig ein wichtiges Argument wenn den
Befürwortern einer schnellen
Energiewende vorgehalten wurde
Deutschland sehr nur für einen
verschwindend kleinen Teil des globalen
CO2-Ausstoßes verantwortlich ihre
Antwort lautete dann Deutschland müsste
deswegen so radikal vorgehen um den
wirklich großen Umweltsünder zu zeigen
wie es denn eigentlich geht am deutschen
Wesen sollte mal wieder die die Welt
gelesen
die Ironie ist nun dass das genaue
Gegenteil eingetreten ist die ganze Welt
hat in den vergangenen Monaten genau
beobachtet wie sich Deutschland in die
größte selbstverschuldete Energiekrise
aller Zeiten gebracht hat in denen die
wechseln Merkel Regierungen ideologisch
verblendet sämtliche politischen Risiken
ihres Kurses ignoriert haben auf diese
Weise konnte Deutschland wenigstens
einen Beitrag zur Weltverbesserung
beitragen als Negativbeispiel wie man es
auf gar keinen Fall machen sollte
ähnliche Beispiele finden sich übrigens
auch in der verfehlten Industrie
migrationsverteidigungs- und
Sicherheitspolitik und man fragt sich
bei dieser Häufung von Fehlschlüssen ob
das Problem nicht tiefer im System
dieser alten Führungsnation liegt
Systeme die nun nicht mehr als Vorbild
für andere Staaten dienen können nun hat
Polen die Chance eine der großen
politischen Mächte des alten Kontinents
zu werden es hat bei dieser Wette aller
Wetten im Gegensatz zu den alten Mächten
eben aufs richtige Pferd gesetzt
allerdings wäre es alles andere als fair
es als bloßen Glücksfall zu tun das war
schon uns seine Nachbarin
geostrategischen viel besseren Riecher
hatten als Berlin oder Paris nein das
alles ist Ausdruck eines viel größeren
mentalitätswandels und eines viel tiefer
liegenden Problems der letzte genannten
Mächte aber auch von Staaten wie Italien
und Spanien deren Eliten begreifen schon
seit vielen Jahren nicht nur nicht mehr
wie diese Welt überhaupt noch tickt
sondern sie haben auch große
Schwierigkeiten damit ihre moralischen
Kompass ausgewogen auszurichten diese
Defizite haben Sie auch schon bei
früheren Krisen unter Beweis gestellt
aber erst der größte Landkrieg in Europa
seit dem Zweiten Weltkrieg wurde zu
ihrer Stunde der Wahrheit der desolate
Zustand der Urteilsfähigkeit ihrer
politischen Führung zeigt sich vor allem
darin dass ich selbst nach
Kriegsausbruch noch über sechs Monate
gebraucht haben um sich das
einzugestehen was die anderen eigentlich
sofort gewusst haben ihr seht also er
russische Überfall auf die Ukraine wird
in Europa viel mehr folgen haben als man
zunächst gedacht hat er hat eine
gewaltige Verschiebung der Macht im
Herzen Europas ausgelöst und die Frage
dabei ist Polen am Ende zu einer Art
politischen Gegengewicht zum Tandem
Paris Berlin innerhalb der Europäischen
Union wird aber an dieser Stelle hätten
wir noch ein paar Fragen an euch glaubt
ihr das Pol am Ende wirklich zu einer
politischen gegengewichtsfirmen Tandem
Paris Berlin werden wird inwieweit
könnte der Block mittelosteuropäischer
Länder die EU-Politik beeinflussen
besteht eurer Meinung nach die Gefahr
dass die EU wie wir sie kennen in zwei
Teile zerfällt und inwieweit sollte die
EU-Kommission überhaupt weiter Druck
Aufwand schauen ausüben wie immer sind
auf eure angeregte Diskussion zu diesem
kontroversen Thema schon mächtig
gespannt ich hoffe dass euch dieses
Video gefallen hat und die vielleicht
dabei auch etwas gelernt habt falls ja
geht uns bitte einen like das mit euren
Freunden und vergessliches Abo mit
Glöckchen und keines unserer Videos mehr
zu verpassen natürlich freuen wir uns
auch jederzeit über eine Spende von euch
mit uns hält dieses Projekt
weiterzuführen den Link dazu findet ihr
in der Beschreibung unter dem Video
mach's gut und bis bald
[Musik]